[Music]
pretty much as soon as photography was
invented in the 1830s
there was a desire to see it in color
the new medium was hyper realistic
but without color incomplete hand
coloring photographs using paints or
dyes
began in europe but the best
hand-colored photographs of the 19th
century
came from japan
[Music]
for over 200 years almost no one outside
of japan
knew what the country looked like the
government closed the borders in 1635
to halt growing colonial influence
mostly from catholic missionaries
that took hold in the late 1500s leaving
the country was forbidden
those who tried were executed and with
some exceptions
contact with the outside world was cut
off for two centuries
but in 1854 a u.s naval expedition of
warships
led by commodore matthew perry forced
japan to open its ports
leading to an influx of travelers and
traders from europe and north america
foreigners coming to japan brought their
clothes their culture
and their cameras photography was
relatively new at the time
and became a lucrative trade for
foreigners in newly opened japan
starting in the 1860s photographers
mostly european but some japanese
documented japan's landscape and people
creating collectible and highly prized
images of japanese culture
photography played very well into this
kind of desire
to learn more about japan this sense i
think of japan as being you know
formally kind of forbidden and beyond
reach and all of a sudden now
somehow knowable the technology of
photography really
played into that because it seemed to
represent
the real it seemed to record reality
photography studios flourished in port
cities like yokohama
and as the medium became more popular
cameras began appearing
in ukiyo a traditional japanese
woodblock prints
too in this 1878 ukioe print a wealthy
japanese woman admires photographic
portraits
with a stamp on the back indicating the
studio of uchiro koichi
a well-known japanese photographer at
the time
but it was a foreigner italian english
feliz bayato
that made expert quality hand coloring
the defining characteristic
of this era of japanese photography he
was the first to really take advantage
of color photography
on a commercial scale in japan and what
he was able to do was
draw on this large body of highly
trained artisans
from the okio and the wood block print
industry
bayado and eventually other foreign
photographers in japan
hired fine artists as their apprentices
to carefully hand color
photographic prints tapping into an
expertise
of patient precision in the application
of color onto flat images
that have been in place in japan for
generations
[Music]
unlike many hand-colored photographs in
europe and north america
which often ended up looking more like
paintings than photographs
japanese artists mostly used watercolors
it created
just a beautiful effect on the
photographs the aesthetic
quality a slight difference to other
kinds of colored photographs
made them very desirable taking
advantage of that pool
of talented highly skilled artisans from
the woodblock print industry
made that all the more possible the
color added to the sense of realism in
these images
which made them even more collectible
but many of these photos
especially the ones staged in studios
have artificial elements
like backgrounds and fake snow added to
dress up the scene
and some constructed images of a society
that was already largely in the past
when they were made
the samurai for example had all but
disappeared by the 1870s
these are models wearing old armor
by the 1880s those same japanese
apprentices that had made foreign
operated businesses profitable
dominated the market with photography
studios of their own
like kusaka bakimbe one of the most
lucrative photographers at the end of
the 19th century in japan
an artist and former apprentice to
foreign photographers
who built on the precedent they set
staging elaborate sometimes
mythic scenes of japanese culture
carefully applying watercolors
and packaging them in expensive photo
albums to sell to foreigners
[Music]
this photo of a woman holding an
umbrella caught in a rainstorm
is a good example of the meticulous work
that photographers like kimbe
put into staging supposedly typical
scenes of japanese life
the rain is simulated by scratches into
the glass plate negative
and the subject's kimono is attached to
the photo studio's background to
simulate wind
these techniques drew unrecognizable
tropes from japanese fine art
in japan i think most directly we can
see the relationship from
ukulele woodblock print art to
photography
composition and more importantly subject
matter
i think you can see really direct
relationship and because
i think even with western audiences the
knowledge of subject matter that was
pictured in woodblock prince
was sort of growing in the 19th century
so it only made sense for photographers
to build on this familiarity
the rise of amateur photography in the
20th century caused a decline of studio
souvenir photography in japan
kodak introduced the browning camera in
1900 and
travelers could take their own photos
plus the introduction of postcards and
mass printed volumes of travel books
meant the images made in japanese photo
studios were less and less precious
and therefore no longer profitable to
spend so much time staging
and then hand coloring studios like
kimbez
shifted their business model to
accommodate a new amateur market
selling supplies and offering darkroom
space to tourists
but for the second half of the 19th
century images like these from japanese
photo studios
even though many were staged and
sometimes already dated stereotypes
had a lasting effect on how outsiders
perceived japanese culture
that image of the woman with the
umbrella relates to
centuries really of the way women were
sometimes portrayed
in japanese arts you have that trope but
what happens when you
translate it into photography is it
takes on the sense
of realistic representation in a way
that
a painting or wood blood print does not
[Music]
that photo of the woman with the
umbrella is often credited to kimbe
but it's also often credited to his
predecessor austrian photographer baron
raymond von stilfried
one of the tricky parts of 19th century
photography in japan
is accurately identifying the original
photographer as studios closed and
photographers retired
they sold their negatives to the
competition who without copyright laws
could claim the photos as their own so
even after copyright laws were
established it was very hard to enforce
so as a result you
see over decades the same images
produced and reproduced under different
studio labels
which is one of the reasons why it's
very difficult to attribute
certain images to a specific
photographer which explains why
this photo of the empress of japan taken
by uchirokuichi in 1872
appears in later photo albums mislabeled
and credited to either felice bayardo or
raymond von stilfried
neither of whom took the picture and if
you want to learn more about this i'd
really recommend this book
by terry bennett uh who i also
interviewed for this episode reading
this was a huge inspiration for this
episode and it's got a lot of great info
about how photography first came to
japan and more detail about the
photographers that were working there in
the 19th century
so check it out if you're interested and
thanks for watching